[Music]
it's a very special day
it looks like Jennifer Lopez's
ten-year-old daughter is following in
her famous Mama's footsteps it's
exciting
the singer shared this sweet video of
her and her daughter Emmy on her
Instagram story driving to a very
important business meeting me and Amy
are off to our first book publishers
meeting for a idea Emmy had for a book
where is it and they didn't just have
one meeting they had several exciting we
have three meetings along with the clip
the proud mama wrote Emmys first meeting
and shared this adorable pic of her
little girl holding up a binder with her
book idea the title Lord helped me the
shades of blue star shares Amy and her
twin brother Maximilian with ex-husband
Marc Anthony the two separated in 2014
and while they're not together they
continue to support each other and their
children it's all about family Anthony
recently joined Lopez and her boyfriend
Alex Rodriguez at Emmys dance recital
also in attendance Max and Rodriguez's
two children Ella Alexander and Natasha
Alexander my girls adore Jennifer she's
she's a great role model and for me I'm
the luckiest spot in the world to be
able to expose my beautiful daughters to
someone as brilliant as Jennifer I'm
glad that he sees me that way then I
would be a good role model to his girls
you know I'm just trying to be a good
mom to mine and
the best I can be for all four of them